the holidays are over next week
it's back to school and for the meps
too they will be back in brussels
at the european parliament from monday
august 29 from wednesday slovakia sends
its ministers presented the priorities of
its presidency of the union in  the
different areas
it is the minister of labor mr ripert
who is starting this series of meetings
watch out this summer an element has changed
the presidents are getting together in threes
to define their priorities
or following the vote for the station wagon if the
united kingdom has left its place
to estonia in this new trio remains to
be seen whether this has an effect on the priorities
for the coming months at the
end of July the council has returned its copy
of the 2017 european budget
it will be the turn of the meps to
floor above the other 2 31
research innovation erasmus more
European funds for the most deprived the council
wants to stimulate growth and create
jobs on the board the experts
what impact the economic development
of  china ensures the european union
where are we in the fight against fraud
it is here behind me in the
european parliament that euro deputies will
hear experts in these matters more than 4000
migrants have died since the beginning of 2016
what conditions and european  from thil
fulfill to benefit from international protection
what will be the definition of a
uniform status for refugees
the deputies will debate it this week
too and in anticipation of the summit on the
management of the migration crisis of the
united nations on september 19 next in
new
york un special adviser karen
abuzayd will meet with meps this
thursday and finally after repeatedly turning down
the invitation former
german european commissioner günther
borgen will finally come to parliament
have there been irregularities related to
pollution standards  applicable to
cars in Europe some MEPs
the firm here is the appointment is made
for schoolchildren in their  Class
for MEPs here in the European Parliament
and until then, welcome back to all